so so I start the class the only way
first day while they are still fresh and
unsuspecting of the class contents of my
own ideology I give them a survey where
ask me simple questions you know the
major the year but also ask them
personal questions where were they born
where they travel during what years they
were in which parts of the country of
the world and I ask them about some of
the course contents you know what do
they know about cruel languages how they
define identity what is the word
identity mean what kind of images does
the word Caribbean sugar in the mind so
very easy questions to answer but
through these questions what I'm about
to see and go to get a sense of both the
personal background but also what kind
of what kind of assumptions they bring
to the course and and then I can use
that to kind of have a beginning where I
can address these fundamental assumption
that we do bring in the course and also
to connect the discussion to the
personal profiles and then that and then
as we progress I can from time to time
check to see how some of the ideas might
have mutated merav evolve through our
discussions so it's a nice benchmark to
start with